hello readers today we're going to talk
about things called affixes
one of the things that i love about the
english language is how flexible its
words can be you can take little word
parts and stick them together to make
new words
if i read something once i've read it if
i read it again now i've reread it that
little re thing tells you oh it's
happening again
there are lots of these little word
parts in english and we call them
affixes
they can come at the beginning or the
end of words at the beginning of words
we call them prefixes
un is a great example of a prefix it
means no or not when you're upset you're
not happy you're unhappy when you are
not available you are therefore
unavailable you see when we put affixes
at the ends of words they're called
suffixes
the suffix full for instance means full
of
so if you're full of joy you're joyful
if you're full of gratitude you're
grateful
and if you're full of power you are say
it with me powerful you are powerful
look at all these words you can make
some common prefixes you might see
include re meaning again as in redo or
reread
dis meaning not or the opposite
as in disuse or disobey
this meaning wrong as in mistake or
misunderstand
some common suffixes you might see
include l y or li meaning a way to do
something as in happily or snappily
less meaning without as in harmless or
wireless
nes meaning a state of being which is
another way of saying it makes nouns as
in happiness or hopefulness
oh did you see what i did there i took
the word hopeful which already has a
suffix in it it means full of hope and i
added nes to it now it's a word that
means the state of being full of hope
that's the magic of affixes they're
these word parts that you can snap on to
pretty much any word in order to change
its meaning so remember prefixes are
word parts that come at the beginning of
words the prefix pre means before as a
little clue and help you remember and
suffixes are word parts that come at the
end of the word
they're going to be lists of these
affixes for you to study but what i
liked doing when i first studied this
stuff was to take those lists and make
them into games make nonsense words
write roots and affixes on little index
cards and shuffle them up into new
combinations and then argue with your
friends and family about what your newly
minted words mean let me shuffle up some
right now
it's sure to be a
dis
petrographic
time dis petrographic okay so that's no
rock pictures adjective forming suffix
it's a describer so i guess i will not
be taking any pictures of rocks
anyway
you can learn anything
dave it out